how many mistakes can a movie have
before it just implodes
with the help of movie mistakes we're
here to find out from major blockbusters
to holiday classics these movies were
all littered with ridiculous mistakes
but all found their audience just the
same
the moment johnny depp dreadlocked an
eyeliner and stepped smoothly off the
mast of his sinking ship but onto the
daca port royal the world
changed pirate movies had been
considered a dead genre for a long time
the country bears another movie based
off a disney park riot had flopped only
a year earlier
but what once had been considered for
direct to video release ended up as one
of the highest grossing films of 2003.
pirates were back in big brash box
office blowout fashion
and suddenly a movie based on a disney
ride was making mad stacks
but a reviewing of the famous first film
of the trilogy reveals a cavalcade of
mistakes
visible crew members and equipment
litter the movie like the man in a tan
cowboy hat and white t-shirt standing
behind jack sparrow as he commands his
crew
on deck you scavenge dogs then there's
the imprints of very modern sneakers
visible in the foreground of a shot of a
dusty workshop floor
moreover the movie's grasp of the 18th
century is tenuous at best
soldiers shoot multiple times with guns
that were invented nearly a century
later captain norrington is promoted to
commodore
despite the fact that commodore was a
posting and not a rank
pirates might have blown audiences away
with its verve and humor but it sure
didn't win any awards for precision
the archetypal disaster movie twister
dazzled audiences with its up-close
portrayal of nature's destructive streak
and the people who chronicle it
tornadoes don't just rip apart the
landscape and twister they suck people
into their murky vortices grow more than
a mile wide and skewer bystanders with
flying shards of metal
by the end of the movie tornadoes seem
less like acts of god and more like gods
themselves
they're life-changingly powerful and
impossible to understand
let alone control natural disasters
really do
upend lives and landscapes of course but
twister played fast and loose with the
actual science of tornadoes in order to
ramp up the spectacle
the tornado that opens the movie is
described as an f5 according to the
fujita scale
which didn't exist in the year the scene
is set later when a burgeoning tornado
is described by its fujita ranking
twister ignores the fact that the rating
can't be determined until the tornado is
gone
but the climax of the film takes the
cake our heroes send a car hurtling into
a tornado and book it through a
cornfield at full tilt without being
delayed by the sturdy stalks
the belts they use to lash themselves to
pipes manage to keep them safe and
relatively unscathed while the tornado
passes directly over them the storm it
seems has a sense of drama it sends some
cows hurtling through the air but it
leaves the leads alone
nothing is subtle in the world of the
phantom the opera beds are shaped like
enormous swans candles are strewn
everywhere by the hundred
velvet is the fabric of choice this
isn't a movie interested in doing
anything by calves
unfortunately that happens to be the
case with the film's missteps as well
some are accidentally hilarious as when
raoul is trapped in a chamber of water
with a slowly lowering grating and then
bubbles suddenly float downwards
a dead giveaway that the film was
reversed some are simply confusing like
megjeri's pants
when she enters the phantom's lair she
wades through water yet one shot later
she's completely bone dry
but the most notable mistake of all has
to do with the phantom's deformity
now we're not talking about the fact
that the movie downgraded the horrifying
malformation of the book and stage
musical to something like a bad sunburn
we're talking about the fact that it
changes over the course of its reveal
before christine rips the mask off the
disfigurement didn't extend much beyond
his jawline only for cg to be added
moments later taking it to his ear
neck and beyond moreover while the
phantom's deformity is luridly pink when
first seen it's almost sallow and
glimpse later in his lair
for being the thing that doomed him to a
life in the parisian sewers the
phantom's terrible face sure is subject
to change
in the age of the omnipresent superhero
the dark knight still stands as a high
water mark of the genre
when the film hit theaters back in 2008
batman fans and newbies alike thrilled
to the growl of christian bale's voice
pete ledger's grimy vision of chaos and
a sleek and modern gotham city crippled
by violence you've changed things
forever then why do you want to kill me
i don't want to kill you it was exciting
honestly groundbreaking and one of the
most celebrated movies of the 2000s
yet there's no level of a claim that can
keep audiences from noticing all the
little continuity flubs that litter the
dark knight
props and actors have a habit of
changing position between shots
like when the joker is interrogated his
hands switch back and forth between
gripping batman's arms from above and
below
the cracks in the wall of the
interrogation room shrink and expand
from covering the surface to barely
indenting it during the thrilling car
chase the tumbler loses a tire when it
drives across a concrete barrier but
then it's mysteriously reattached
between
shots the movie is so packed with action
that it's easy to miss these odd
missteps
but return to the steely streets of
gotham city often enough and even the
most ardent fat band will be able to
pick them out
directed by martin scorsese the 2002
epic gangs of new york chronicled the
world of 19th century five points
a new york city neighborhood as vibrant
as it was deadly
gangs vied for power people fought and
died and the winds of change never
stopped blowing bringing immigrants
freed slaves pickpockets and all
other manner of misfits and dreamers
into the mix led by leonardo dicaprio
and the ever electrifying daniel
day-lewis the film garnered positive
reviews and 10 oscar nominations
another scorsese classic another
american fable
like any historical drama however gangs
of new york managed to foul off
quite a lot of its details bill the
butcher might growl about who will do
dirty deeds for a nickel but he's
missing the fact that he was living at
least three years before the coining of
the first nickel a man is taken down on
a theater bananas that weren't yet
traded in the u.s surrounding him
flags featuring 50 stars drape a stage
roughly a century before the u.s
would in fact have 50 states this might
have been a story about an era long
past but its mistakes were utterly
modern
the flexible nature of magic in the
world of harry potter allowed filmmakers
a large degree of freedom
apparition allowed instant travel souls
could be fractured implanted and linked
everything from fire to bubbles could be
produced by the magic wands every major
character carried on their person
it was big it was wild and its
possibilities were thoroughly explored
time travel however makes fools of even
the most dedicated director
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
features it heavily and the movie is
accordingly packed with mistakes and
confusingly divergent shots
lines and scenery when hermione punches
malfoy for example she's first seen
turning away from him before she swings
yet when harry and hermione watch her do
it after going back in time she faces
him head on from the very beginning and
throws a markedly different punch
this is to say nothing of how confusing
it is that immediately after turning
back time hermione claims it to be 7 30
despite the fact that a bell is audibly
ringing out that it is in fact 7 o'clock
7 30. where were we at 7 30. most
frustratingly when hermione throws a
stone through hagrid's window it's first
seen breaking a base in half
it completely shatters when the moment
is revisited you might be able to fit
time travel into the plots but you can't
guarantee that everything makes sense
the second time around
is there any movie that says hollywood
more than titanic
from its legendary prophets to the fact
that more than 20 years later people are
still making jokes about it
jack i want you to draw me like one of
your french girls it was as big bold and
glitzy as the movie industry itself
it's impossible to imagine the world
without titanic so huge was its impact
it wasn't just an icon of the 1990s love
stories or any featured actor's career
it's just an icon period yeah titanic is
as riddled with mistakes as any other
movie in this video
a rose living in 1912 comments on
sigmund freud's theories about the male
preoccupation with size
despite the fact that freud wouldn't
publish material on that subject until
1920.
freud who is he is a passenger jack runs
to catch the ship while his friend
sports a modern swedish army rucksack
commonly available in army surplus
stores today and very much
unavailable in his own time the
unsinkable margaret brown played to
perfection by kathy bates refers to
herself as molly a nickname the actual
woman never used until
after the sinking of the titanic so it
goes in the world of blockbuster films
where sweeping audiences away requires
the work of thousands
as a result sometimes you make a hit the
likes of which the world has seldom seen
but you probably still get a few things
wrong
for many the christmas season isn't
complete without a screening or two of
the 1983 classic a christmas story
ralphie's pink bunny suit is childhood
mortification personified the leg lamp
can be purchased from a variety of
retailers and even those who've never
heard of comic strip hero red rider
could likely tell you of his famous bb
gun
you'll shoot your eye out kid but once
one hits their 100th screening of the
holiday tale it becomes hard not to
notice its cut corners and misplaced
scenery
the parker home is so subject to
teleporting objects that it might as
well be in the world of harry potter
a christmas bow appears and disappears
from a lampshade over the course of the
scene in which the dogs steal the turkey
the leg lamp when first lifted from the
box has no light fixture on which to
place a shade
then gains one when it comes time to
light it and then a jar of pickles sits
on the kitchen table before a scene in
which ralphie's mom comes up from the
basement with the jar placing it on the
table
time travel teleportation outright magic
nope just the nature of filmmaking in
which props get switched out
bows fall off and no one can remember
when a jar was retrieved from where
two other spider-men have inhabited the
legendary blue and red suit since toby
maguire brought the web slinger to
cinematic light but spider-man 2
still stands as a joyous monument of
superhero cinema
the action the romance the tragedy and
what a cast bringing it to life
style to embody their comic counterparts
with almost surreal perfection
mad science drives a man insane altruism
brings a young man with astonishing
powers to the brink of death and a moral
emerges from the chaos as shining as the
city spider-man protects
doing good is the duty of all who are
capable something less shiny however is
what the movie gets wrong
remember the scene when auto octavius's
fusion experiment goes horribly awry
octavius warns the onlookers that what
they're about to see is dangerous and
then arms himself with special goggles
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
fasten your seat belts yet mere feet
away the onlookers are apparently
totally okay without them
and how about tritium the substance
that's so rare that octavius claims
there are only 25 pounds of it on earth
he's not entirely wrong as triteam is in
fact quite rarely found in nature
but it can be produced through man-made
nuclear reactions of the sort of world
famous scientists like octavius would
doubtlessly have access to
so goes the way of hollywood super
science ever changing always fantastic
and extraordinarily easy to screw up
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you